yeah what do I know why do I know damn
it
make a joke about gyms for them now
before jacksepticeye has stopped playing
happy wheels he stopped that episode 100
you could continue his legacy my
apprentice but happy wills is the
stupidest game on the planet I am never
touching that [ __ ] again
[Music]
like I'm not anti cymatic or whatever
it's called okay so don't get the wrong
idea
why am I playing this what's the [ __ ]
point I mean I love [ __ ] hapless geez
what what is this download on the App
Store I got a I got a download this
right now happy wheels on my phone we
are truly living in the cybernetic
future
all right so happy wheels where the [ __ ]
is it
happy bicycle on crazy Hills happy
wheels adventure 2017 happy zombie
wheels happy wheels duty cycle happy
bicycle that's me
let's [ __ ] my for that span that's my
fine art okay start list here we go oh
she can suck himself off look at that
dog huh [ __ ] suck my own dick jump
suck my own dick jump suck my own dick
jump if only life for this [ __ ] god damn
it
Wow these apps are actually way better
than then it playing actual happy we
should be playing the real happy wheels
the real happy wheels is my
favorite game of all time welcome to
happy wills episode 101 let's look at
the best ones this month swords oh I
love Thor throw you take a [ __ ] sword
and then you shove it up Timmy's [ __ ]
it's Timmy doing a site annex I'd no no
no no we can't show that here we go here
we go Timmy was that your name I forgot
I mean I don't care I don't care I'm
having fun oh [ __ ] hey we made it how
about that how about god damn wall
come on come on Oh why am I doing this
that's so [ __ ] stupid
it's the same levels over oh my god
it's Pogo man versus naked girls that's
that's a little girl that's alright
oh that's fine I've been [ __ ] by worse
[Music]
here we go
don't hit my ass what did I say
[Music]
all right for [ __ ] sake hey yeah we
meet again why is this goddamn [ __ ]
level so [ __ ] hard I don't remember
this game being so [ __ ] god damn
lay still honey lay still and trust me
do you trust me
yes I mean I mean yes get in the box
Ultra yay yay get in the box
[Music]
Oh [ __ ] pissing me off
I [ __ ] hate this piece of [ __ ] but 20
Cyril hey hey hey how you doing my name
is Jeff
Berenice why paratus
alright here we go [ __ ] yes
that's right I'm the happy wheels King
King King hail booty pop [ __ ] 12
weapons
[Music]
so now in happy was you can press fresh
stuff oh and so ok Wow whoa whoa dude
harpoon dodge to browse ok let's do that
boom right here we go
I am except you gotta click now to start
this alright level 1 don't [ __ ] me I got
you I've got you harpoons I'll don't you
break oh you missed me you missed me
oh god oh my god I got it okay just okay
duck Duck Duck
oh my god oh oh boy Oh golly holy [ __ ]
that was a matrix [ __ ]
[Music]
why are we still here
just to suffer every night I can feel my
leg
and I are
and my fingers
[Music]
Aynsley
you put a spell on me
I don't want to play this [ __ ] why why
the answer is simple the body I lost
become lost
don't stop hurt hurting sits microwave
all till there you feed the to help you
and Ballmer can give back our best
[Music]
I see now I understand what I must do
you're freaking sleep we're great we
don't have to play this game anymore the
smell is gone now I can finally play
what I want
good one we're now looking for brain
transplants for Ainslie please if you
have a brain donate down below any
amount would be any or all your money
would be would be would make such a
difference